- We've seen a number of
high-profile criminal cases lately,
and sometimes, something goes wrong
and a mistrial is declared.
And unfortunately, people
often misunderstand
what a mistrial is.
Now, people know that that means
that the trial has to end.
But people think that that means
that the defendant just
goes off scot-free,
that's not true.
A mistrial would be more
accurately described as a mulligan.
If a mistrial is declared,
then the prosecutor can just
simply bring the charges again.
Sometimes they do, sometimes they don't.
This happens if there is an
error that is so prejudicial
that it cannot be overcome
through instructions,
or sometimes when the jury
is deliberating for so long
but they can't come to
a decision, they hang,
and therefore a mistrial was declared
so that the prosecutor
can start the trial again
with a new jury pool.
So, mistrial doesn't mean
the defendant goes free,
it just means the prosecutor
can bring the charges again.
So, now you know next
time I see you in court.